if you a dog you get a dog like the
nfl's gonna find you if i went to hcu
they got a great history
just being myself i could just really
relax be unapologetically black
that pass is intercepted on the return
for north carolina central brian mills
i've been
saying i'm gonna go to the league since
like high school has been my plan a i
really didn't have a plan b
my time was now 2021 draft has always
been a goal of mine to enter into
knowing the type of player you are you
don't really have to be like that player
to the left or a writer you just be
brian mills the family here the culture
here
is second to none and i've been coaching
for you know 22 23 years in
the hbcu circle there's nothing like it
you see guys that transfer from other
fps schools and
sometimes they're taken back with with
all the love they're shown to them
and you know it's about us growing young
men and that's why i do it and that's
why i'm sure most coaches in hvcu
do it as well my grandpa's impact on me
was bigger at football at the end of the
day it's right it's about being
a righteous person of being a jazz
person he always taught me to do the
right thing
he's just a special kid he's probably
more focused than his siblings
football was his thing so we were all
over the place doing pot warner and
all of the different categories and
classes of football
being that was the sport that he loved
he uh he
got good at it every day i'm like dang
i'm really about to get drafted i'm
really going to nfl
and then they stopped hitting me for a
little bit then like today actually when
i woke up i'm like wow it's thursday
it's probably next week and that's about
the fly
six come on bend them arms more seven
there you go let your body work get your
back lower there you go that's how we
work
24 7. man ah fight through that fight do
that let's get it come on yup let's go
we ain't done yet hard work on changes
only way to be great
game time we ain't wishing dream chasing
baby i think it's special for any young
man
that makes it to the national football
league regardless of the situation
uh but when you see a young man that was
raised by his grandparents
comes across the country to play for
some of the guys that he's never met and
just zoomed with
and went the recruiting process when you
put your faith in something
and you really work hard at it to reach
your goals i think that makes it even
more special
at first people were like not proud to
be from palm beach like oh i'm from los
angeles but
the closer i get like the more proud i'm
from where i'm at
where i'm born so it's just it's
exciting to be like a representative
for this city coach wander had like a
huge impact he always pushed me to do be
great
always telling me to chase my dreams you
know and that's what i'm doing still to
this day
ryan was he was a leader he wanted to be
involved with whatever was going on
you know just to hear him just be
rewarded just to see all that hard work
and effort that he put forth
pay off would just be uh just exciting
for us to hear that
just told you that hbcu players could
make it just like lsu players can make
it georgia players could make it you
know i made it to the senior bowl
i got to invite to that the sky's the
limit we only had them for one year here
but i think that
there's so much more to brian mills and
i think whoever gets him
they'll really be able to mold him get
him like they want him yeah right now we
got to pingle mall
just uh looking at some outfits to get
for a draft day tomorrow
all right these are shoes i got right
now i'm about to get this for sure
man i'm excited i really got to get
drafted
[Music]
you're
uh today's the first round of nfl draft
everything officially begins uh
so any moment you can really get that
phone call from an organization saying
they want you
what's up with you hey
[Music]
16.
it's a great day life by the change
you know whether he gets drafted or not
he's a good one
but if your hope is only for today
you're a man most
miserable without love
the foundation doesn't even work love is
the key
he knows that i love him three of the
nfl draft
you know i remain optimistic positive my
head up high
this is the same thing about just being
undrafted
so i'm just looking forward to all of
this you know it doesn't matter how you
start it's how you finish your life
now officially i got signed a contract
to be i see hogs but it's gonna happen
but yeah i'm excited i don't care if i
need that or not
ryan mills db out of north carolina
central signing with the seahawks
i'll catch you around i'm a diamond and
i can't do anything
so yeah